if you define eastern europe for example
as the russian border east to the ural
mountains if you consider that part of
eastern europe then yes putin has
security concerns from his own
population that wants a free government
he faces no threat from ukraine he faces
no threat from nato uh this is all a
narrative he has created to
assist him uh in his long-standing
effort to re-establish russian hegemony
within the space of the former soviet
union that's what this whole thing is
about there is no moral equivalence
between russian security concerns uh and
the legitimate security concerns of
countries like ukraine so should the u.s
and nato be putting anything on the
table for president putin or or would
that just be indulging him
i i think he sees weakness in the west i
think the i think he sees the u.s
withdrawal from afghanistan as a major
sign of american retrenchment he can see
the evident
divisions in nato today enough another
proof he doesn't have any security
concerns
is that nato can barely walk and chew
gum at the same time the germans have
all but declared themselves pacifist the
french are uh not being helpful uh and
putin's trying to take advantage of that
whatever he does in ukraine he's doing
his dead level best to split nato so
what should the west be doing then the
u.s and nato are imposing sanctions now
moving troops more troops into the
region sending more military support to
ukraine or all three
well i've been saying all three for
about a month now look the effort that
nato has undertaken is to deter putin
from engaging in military hostilities
against ukraine essentially by
threatening punishment after the
invasion takes place
for the reasons i just said i don't
think putin gives any credibility to
those threats he faced similar threats
when he annexed the crimea and
essentially took control of eastern uk
crane in 2014 and and i'm worried he
thinks he can get away with it again i
think the first thing that we ought to
do and germany stands in the way is we
ought to tell putin no natural gas
will ever flow through that pipeline
unless and until all russian military
forces are withdrawn from all countries
in europe that object to their presence
so that's a good starting point do you
think american and british troops should
be sent into ukraine or would that be a
step too far
no i think we should send u.s and other
nato forces uh into ukraine we've got
some there now training and assisting
the ukrainian military i'm not saying we
should send these forces into fight but
i think it would be very instructive to
russian generals looking through their
field glasses across the ukrainian
border to see some american and british
flags and say to themselves i wonder
what that means
yeah i'm interested in this how do you
think you served under him how do you
think donald trump would be dealing with
this he had a curious
relationship with putin
well he's already said that
that he doesn't favor many of the steps
biden has taken look trump doesn't think
in policy terms it's sort of foolish
talking about what his reaction would be
because it won't be
uh in any kind of uh
policy-oriented sense it will be an
opportunity to criticize
biden you know for example in the case
of afghanistan trump would have
withdrawn from afghanistan too but he
criticized biden for the way it was done
and i think you'll see something similar
here too i mean he's hinting i see
hinting on a the golf course that he'd
run in 2024 what would your view be of
that
i don't think he's going to run in 2024
he doesn't want to lose again he doesn't
want to go down in history as a loser he
will talk about it incessantly
until the very last minute when i think
he will try to be a king maker among
republican candidates for the nomination
but i don't think he'll run again you
don't and just to come back to ukraine
how do you see this given where we are
this evening how do you see this playing
out in the coming weeks
how do you view it
well i don't think putin has made a
decision on uh what he's going to do i
think he's doing continuous
round-the-clock cost-benefit analysis
he's got uh the momentum he's got the
initiative he's calling the tune we're
simply reacting
but i think he will find ways not simply
to focus on ukraine but to play into
these divisions in nato i mean it is
unbelievable given its history that
germany germany of all countries isn't
taking the strongest possible stance
against the use of military force across
border in europe putin sees that and he
will try and build on it and increase
the tension within nato reducing nato
increases russian influence it's a
pretty straight equation okay 30 seconds
left you're worried about unity in nato
or germany and so forth are you worried
about boris johnson's eyes being off it
because he's got all his domestic
problems here with
lockdown parties and so forth
well look i mean these these domestic
issues consume every president every
prime minister i i think the uk
government frankly in the last let's say
30 days in the ukraine crisis has been a
better leader of the western alliance
than the biden administration so uh if
if the controversy over the party is
helping the government
focus on ukraine uh all the better okay
john bolton appreciate your time this
evening thanks very much indeed